there are video game characters we love
put the turn around from trying to get
back in the chase
the resonating strike and the ace goes
through for peanut
there are characters we hate the only
feasible explanation i could possibly
think of
for somebody trying to play this
character legitimately is if they're
just trying to be a total douche bag to
somebody
there are even some characters that we
love to hate [ __ ] damage
low [ __ ] cooldowns a wall that blocks
everything a knock up and an old that
gives him 50
armor penetration but then there are
those characters who are
loved only by a small group of weird
degenerates who
should hate them sorry viper mintz she's
deter now i see you viper mains out
there already getting defensive but
hear me out even people who used to
player admit that she's effed here
and that stands for failure we're gonna
we're just gonna put this in
a tier of its own so it's time to admit
you drank the kool-aid and ask yourself
the important question
why did you pick viper why did you join
the cult of low tier
trash
every game has that one character who
absolutely
sucks but people play anyway and the
newest in-depth key to that
cult of low tiers is valorent's most
toxic agent
viper they call me a monster shall i
prove them right
she has been pegged as one of the worst
least playable agents in the game since
day one and that's whether you're a pro
or a scrub
her alt is just not good her all most of
the time is a liability
i feel like a lot of times it's even
it's it's you're actually putting
yourself in a disadvantage using her all
i'm gonna go ahead and put viper down
here because literally nobody touches
her
while viper and her abilities do
actually look really cool
they're anything but cool in-game never
mind the guy that you heard to your
right right behind you to your right
never mind now you hear them there you
go there you go uh-huh uh-huh you could
have probably abused it this guy didn't
have a good aim there you go
boom now he's going to the right there
you go boom here we go here we go
[Applause]
viper often falls short when you compare
her to other agents in valorum
phoenix's flame wall deals actual more
damage and is thicker than vipers so
viper's wall can be as wide as it is but
if it's too thin and easy to push
through
there really isn't much use to it i
don't know i don't know what they need
to do to viper maybe
maybe her ults i don't know she she just
kind of feels especially when there's a
sova on an enemy team
viper feels so useless and that's just
the tip of the iceberg
for example viper's toxic screen
actually gives her location away to
enemies
making it more of a liability than an
asset her viper pit requires her to stay
inside of it or else it collapses
limiting its utility and on top of all
of that
viper is really complicated so you have
to spend hours mastering her
and be good at valrant to even get close
to using her at her full potential
she is complicated like you need to
really change the way you play
and people don't want to put that time
in so if you don't know how to use her
why bother at all but of course the
viper mains out there
have already joined the cult and once
you're in
you're in people join the cult of low
tiers for all kinds of reasons but one
of the most common ones is that playing
a low to your character
is basically like playing a competitive
game on hard mode after all
if you beat somebody while you're
playing one of the worst characters in
the game
that has to mean you're better than them
right and
even if she's not that strong if you
know how to play
and read the game because of what you're
doing you're
basically making both teams play on what
your moves are
and in my opinion if you're enough if
you have enough
experience and the ability to read the
game
that that alone in a competitive match
that gives you so much power mixwell is
one of a small group of prominent voices
who think that all viper needs to be
great is a
small push in the right direction viper
is a challenging one
because i think she's really really good
i think she's just missing a little bit
she's missing a little bit of utility so
like she's
almost a tier i do think that she's good
in theory um but nobody's really playing
with her no one's really kind of
unlocked her true potential
and so despite remaining a near
permanent fixture at the bottom of the
competitive tier list
in the right hands viper can be exactly
what she was designed to be
deadly
[Music]
one enemy
but valerian is still a very new game so
viper's future as a member of the cult
of low tiers is still pretty uncertain
she could get buffed tomorrow and be
hanging with the top tiers holding her
own
or at least that's what all you viper
mains keep telling yourselves
but you're in luck because viper isn't
the only member of the cult of low tiers
and a low tier doesn't need buffs to win
big tournaments
all they need is a hero who can champion
them and take them to the highest level
of competition
take pikachu for example going from
smash 64 to melee pikachu got weaker and
slower and he just couldn't compete with
the game's top characters
so almost no one picked him for most of
melee's competitive existence
that is until axe came along seeing that
hedgehog attempt by m2k trying to close
it out as quickly as he could
oh entertain a really bad spot right now
let's see what's gonna happen he gets
the up smash
that's axe taking it oh my gosh an axe
can't believe
it he can't believe that he moves on
winners finals
to face hungrybox now axe's devotion to
his low tier of choice was
tested many times he's got one hp
i'll
but like any real member of the cult of
low tiers
axe was determined to prove that he
could win with pikachu
that all the hard work and dedication he
put into mastering the character
wasn't for nothing and he was right he's
going to death
here we go this is what's he going to
get here
thunder 85 he's on stage
[Music]
is your smash summit a champion x did it
he's done it a pikachu has won a major
smash summit eight i don't know what to
say i just uh i've been working really
hard for this
and uh i don't know it's a long time
coming it's just crazy to me
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks to axe's smash summit 8 victory
pikachu finally had his first
significant tournament win
but as incredible as his accomplishment
was people aren't exactly rushing to
main pikachu
axe is still pretty much the only
pikachu mane at the top because
being a member of this particular cult
can be kind of lonely
and people haven't really changed their
minds about the character
pikachu is just not top tier material if
you made it this far into the video
you're either a card carrying member of
the cult of low tier
or you're interested in joining so let
me warn you
not every low tier you pick is going to
have a champion who wins a huge
tournament
and proves that they're worth playing
after all
some characters aren't worth meaning
some are just too terrible and
exist only to annoy everyone around them
and the mascot for
that kind of annoying unplayable useless
low tier
is league of legends teemo
um the teemo thing was kind of like at
the on the moment here the moment we're
just like
oh what should we land against on them
we were like okay let's get timo cause
rayman's always like
teemu is the best with very few
exceptions teemo has basically gone
unpicked in league of legends pro play
for
years and here's youtuber scooch
explaining just how bad he
is darius wins against teemo mordekaiser
wins against teemo garen
wins against teemo and even if they get
bullied in lane it doesn't matter
because they all offer something later
whereas teemo offers no hard cc and can
blind one person
do you know how ass that is now to be
fair to teemo
early on he was actually pretty decent
he was intended as a counter to tanky
damage dealers
very nice job coming out turtle it's up
on the sneaky the 80 carry draw
the ignite takes him down and if special
is able to pick himself up a kill
teemo coming out of nowhere and he gets
him with the mushroom
but after a 2014 nerf teemo basically
faded away from pro play entirely
appearing only as an accident or a troll
pick what
are you serious i think they're uh i
think they've gotten to the point where
they're so confident
in this best of three that they are
straight up trolling
the thing i'm super excited about is the
fact that we're gonna get to see
the zed
i mean i imagine it's a hard stomp i
mean in what universe
does teemo lose to anything if really i
mean
but outside of pro play teemo is
actually pretty popular
he still gets plenty of new skins riot
sells teemo merch for reasons i cannot
explain
and he's become something of a mascot
for league of legends solo queue hell
[Music]
the [ __ ] out of here you little guy
better be
careful trading against me but you see
this is why i warned you these days kimo
only exists to be annoying
it sucks to play against him or with him
he's the ultimate troll pick
look terrible characters often attract
as many people as they scare away
and if you're one of the poor fools who
got suckered in
it happens to the best of us the love
hate relationship we have with the games
we play
might go a long way to explain how these
questionable choices still find their
niche
whether you worship viper pikachu or
even teemo
the cult of low tiers is powerful its
history is long and its reach is vast
because we all love to rebel we all love
to play off meta
to succeed no matter how hard the
situation may be
and to dream of one day making our low
tier great
so viper mains for all the meming i've
done on you
i salute you because you are just the
latest in a long legacy of heroes
trying to make a low tier work the
mission of the low tier main is an
honorable one
we all wish we could do what you're
doing but there is no [ __ ] way
i'm putting myself through that thanks
for watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub button and ring that
notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
you